bene ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video io sono valigie oggi
sono su the binding of isaac che è un
gioco che ho già portato un po di volte
sul canale tra l'altro ragazzi voglio
fare un esperimento avete visto i veniva
episodi di panico paese se non l'avete
visti recuperate ve li voglio provare a
fare questo video senza fare neanche un
taglio sarà il dito che giampiero sarà
più contento di montare la sua vita che
non deve fare niente se non guardarsi il
video anche lui niente proviamo a
giocarci perché ragazzi ho notato e sono
molto contento di questi fatti vi
ringrazio che vi sono piaciuti e così
tanto le altre puntate non me
l'aspettavo mai sinceramente perché un
gioco un po di nicchia levan di golasa
ma vi sono talmente piaciute ragazze ho
detto proprio dai ragazzi come un
gameplay puro gli dava indigo paese puro
nel senso senza tagli senza nulla quindi
come si fa una giocata dall'inizio alla
fine
mi dite che cosa ne pensate nei commenti
ragazzi dell'allora queste ragazzi e la
pagina dei the intent cosa sono i take
that sono però anche un volume di voce
abbastanza normale perché in genere per
intrattenere cioè quelli enfatizzano un
po però se continua così per un'ora poi
mi ritrovo che non c'è la voce quindi
perdonatemi cerca di avvicinare il
microfono vediamo se miglioriamo allora
su cosa i carter si sbloccano durante
quando compì diverse quando un portiere
non vedi che non posso tagliare quindi
parlare bene quando completi diverse
challenge sul gioco neo sbloccati e non
sbloccati pochi veramente pochi e allora
vorrei provare a vedere se riesco a
farla con o con isaac preo con isaac
ragazzi non lo so è perché diciamo che è
molto strano tenter isaac praticamente è
strano da dire che cosa fatta in the
dark perché ogni utente dal proprio non
siamo facciamo leiser ci ho ripensato a
favore alto sticazzi lega perché isaac
può portare al massimo oggetti e questa
cosa mi mib i green già facciamoli elite
let's go per niente il re tiget isaac
può portare solo al massimo oggetti di
una cosa che un pochino mi mi grigia non
ho ancora mai provato tainted lilith la
prima volta l'account è in sharing con
la mia ragazza quindi è per quello che
vedete che ha sbloccato delle robe
allora vediamo c'è lancia un feto questo
è quello che fate inter lilith la lancia
un feto ok va bene promesso hard
protetta difficile non ho fatto normal
porca vacca o sbagliato scusatemi la
faremo a partire hard life che ce lo
faccio avesse un po però abbiamo
scoperto che lanciamo feti a me tanto
era l'inizio bene scorpio poison tears
va bene lancio feti e le mie lacrime
fanno danno nel tempo perché ovviamente
avveleno la gente ma che figo stufato e
una frase è un po strani eva è un caso
che io lancio la mia dalla mia pancia
sostanzialmente ok bene perfetto questo
è partito ragazzi è veramente forte fa
un danno pazzesco sto coso ce fa
veramente fa veramente un danno
allucinante per essere un c'è allora
esiste un oggetto che è simile che si
chiama con joinet friends so se si dice
così
italiano perché non solo italiano e in
inglese vuol dire meno quindi non so
neanche l'italiano perché mi confondo
malori e concede il freno è molto simile
che è praticamente questa roba che tu
l'anci non lo lanci data e rimane sempre
attivo ed è molto simile ma è molto più
forte uno perché passa attraverso gli
oggetti stappare due perché leva un
sacco ci avrebbe veramente figo sto coso
scusa ma prende anche gli oggetti non
rifarebbe ca peccato perché sarebbe
stata una figata stà cosa che già è già
abbastanza forte quindi va beh
normalmente lilith la versione normale
di lilith ti permette di di avere dei
come schiavone personaggi aggiuntivi
free france non mi ricordo me si
chiamano porco demonio lo stare attento
pin che è veramente scarso ma anche
colpito io con la mia ragazza li chiamo
puzzo liquidi cosi quelli che è che
prendiamo quando quando si chiama da
isaac non so come si chiami normalmente
france sono rilevate sticazzi non fanno
figure del the kakà e andiamo al piano
di sotto allora base di qua ragazzi per
aver la possibilità in più sulla tre
giorni perché normalmente potrei saltare
il primo piano delle fogne perché più
difficile stanzialmente almeno o un
oggetto in più
ok è veramente utile il fatto che tu
possa passare attraverso gli oggetti
porca vacca solo per via danno manuale
costa fare per far fuori i nemici
veramente utile sta cosa e potevo
esplodergli tutti subito ma me ne sono
accorto un'ora dopo fa niente dai
mischiato solo di prender danno è
veramente figo no veramente porco del
demonio cosa va colpito non ho visto non
ho visto mannaia me e veramente strano
raga fare un video senza tagli infatti
non capiterà mai perché proprio sono
rari i giochi in cui per forza cosa
faccio saltare perché c'è un attenta
l'argentina tattica e si va a togliere
5.19 ott altro che culo trovato anche al
piano di sotto
c'è il piano con lamon sky cazzata non è
male buono non è male la canon e male
non mi è sempre piaciuta perché
veramente incazzato sarà stamos china
incredibile comunque ho avuto veramente
culo a trovare sia una tenda che una
botola non lo stesso nella seconda
stessa bomba perfetto dicevo è veramente
particolare ragazzi fare un video senza
tagli ed è veramente difficile se non
sei abituato a farlo è molto difficile
cioè mi sento è un po come se fosse uno
youtuber alle prime armi perché è molto
difficile tenere alto l'intrattenimento
senza tagli perché se coinvolta che si
abituato a quello magari quando fai
gameplay ci sono momenti di silenzio
tipo questo l'avrebbe rettamente
tagliato per non far vedere quanto
faccio schifo però non lo posso fare
quindi stig a chi però non si può che
peccato che non puoi aprire le cose
attraverso gli ostacoli sarebbe stata
una figata all right
allora ho beccato due danni totalmente
inutili speriamo che questo mi media 2
cuoricini argento non c'è male non c'è
male
tra l'altro ha tra l'altro non ha aperto
la treasure capirla tra l'altro volevo
dire che a quanto pare li dente d'elite
parte con la con più lentezza del solito
perché parti adesso sono a 0 80 prima
stavo a 0 60
minchia lega sono buoni tutti e due no
madonna allora 1 ora che allora uno
ragazzi eden comiso ha ripetuto come se
ci fosse un taglio ma vi devo ricordare
che non ci sono 1 ragazzi è d'emblée
since che questo qua
meno male che non me l'ha preso perché
magari c'era sta cosa che potevi
prendere gli oggetti così meno male
l'altro è bimbo che praticamente ti da
un cuore è però nicchia ragazzi non lo
so
bomb tac con lo chiamo bomb perché non
avevano chiamo punto mi sono confuso
perché bomb e quello che ti dà i soldi
queste dark bam praticamente ti cattura
i cuori rossi e in cambio ti da cuori
argentati che non è male che non è male
per niente ragazzi non è male per niente
vediamo dove ci porta anche hayden
placing però è raramente veramente utile
ragazzi a me dai madonna quanti cazzata
stamos careca guarda quanto cacchio leva
è incredibile dai scusatemi è pazzesca
change my mind c'è di meglio c'è di
meglio o quando non avevo visti quelli
ecco questo è l'oggetto più di merda del
gioco scusate mi fa veramente schifo
tira 9 monete stupide basta non è anche
tradate quante 8 neanche 9 perfetto
oppure ho contato io male non lo so
allora da satana ragazzi abbiamo niente
perché fanno schifo gli ori sotto le
scora che allora in realtà in realtà io
sto facendo sto facendo io cercherò di
fare ma other che sarebbe il boss che
fai serie c a costruire il coltello
quindi quello che avete visto già in
passato nei video se avete seguite
vecchi video di il binding of isaac non
ho preso due danni con un pirla
stavo dicendo non sono mai riuscito non
sono mai riuscito a batterlo durante un
gameplay registrato l'ho battuto
soltanto la decima volta che lo che mi
ci sono scontrato no ho fatto una
cazzata non lo voglio soprattutto
soltanto la decima volta che lo ho
contate le volte in cui mi sono
scontrato e non stavo registrando quindi
non so se riuscirò a battere in questo
video molto probabilmente no
però provo a fare quello perché vale
essendo il posto diventa l'unico che non
mi dà a noia perché appunto porca vacca
appunto è l'unico abbastanza nuovo
voglio dire poi c'è l'altro che ancora
non ho fatto ma va bene va bene va bene
ok perfetto
stavo pensando ragazzi che c'è anche the
beast che per un vicolo me si sblocca
the beast lo sblocca lo si sia arrivando
da mamma a capirla
beh potrei provare a fare dei visti in
realtà ragazzino niente scherzava
cellule beast calo che avete idea
facciamo depist che è un altro che è
ancora più difficile di quel di moda c'è
confronto modera un tutorial
proviamo a fare le pizze vediamo che
succede porco demonio non la chiave per
aprirla qua non c'è niente
non devo prendere danno sono è finita la
run ok
bene allora facciamo così de loa no che
mi ha recuperato re generation perfetto
allora niente volevo fare un altra roba
per raggiungere le piste cose che devo
far niente volgare da madre basta quindi
non c'è bisogno che io poi vada nel
nella sprint degli altri
le miniere quello che ti sono
incasinatissimo e non ci vado ragazzi
hawaii ea my brothers perfetto volevo
volevano usare volevo usare the lovers e
prendere un cuore solo e l'altro foglio
prendere al dark bam
ma niente madonna non c'è non c'è una
chiave manca a pagarla hanno forse a
pagarla ci aspettava da prendere allo
storno perché non ho la chiave per lo
store porco demonio
ecco una buona tattica quando non hai
chiavi con lei e robe del genere e
utilizzare per un casino utilizzare the
lost e sperare che te la cavino nello
specchio problema che minchia senato
nello specchio moio la società io se
vado nello specchio ma lapio intercooler
che la metà basta ve lo dico io però ci
prova perché sono un temerario ci provo
io me ne vado into the specchio into the
spider vers
cenate inter 4 all'altro i nostri kakà o
una bomba una chiave rischio tantissimo
raga perché tanto c'è anche quando altra
tenta rischio tantissimo perché se vi è
un danno sono morto
però almeno posso sperare di trovare un
oggetto di più perché veramente mi
servono larga o faccio fare tutto alla
tensione cos'è questo justice ora è no
madonna madonna della madonna
mammamia nove ragazzi veramente sono
diventato all'improvviso 60 anni però
posto una chiave è let's roll di am
press di en place che cacchio fa che non
mi ricordo meglio rage green power
chissà che ti evoca ma non pagato al
medico lo scafati nel prezzo c'è un
vuoto di memoria l'avessi kaki allora la
chiave cielo posso accedere posso
accedere allo store e vedere se riesco a
comprare qualcosa avrei tanto con la
parte di coltello la prendiamo anche se
non ci serve una sega se ne fa tanto
l'abbiamo fatto è un peccato perché ci
sono due tinte draga a rischio nono mela
rischio ragazzo ne sbatto sbattere scopo
va bene allora me ne torno al allo shop
paolo pesando preso
no non l'ho preso parola treasure allora
allora posso fare svariate cose io
adesso aprirei lo store così comprano
una bomba e la chiave sperando che ci
siano entrambe spero allora chi è
perfetto
questo meno male che sono un pedofilo
shop è la 3 chi è questo questa è nuovo
ecco alcuni oggetti nuovi purtroppo non
so cosa siano mi dispiace che è andato
un però avanti magari visto che non ci
sono tagli
vediamo se riesco a perché devo vedere
cosa fanno certi oggetti e non lo so se
non controllo
allora questa cosa normalmente l'avrei
tagliata in video ma non posso farlo
allora alabaster box porca vacca miche
buonissima raga ceti spa una ricarica
lentissimamente etis fauna una angel
room una certa c'è veramente
potentissima non ho ben capito cioè
credo che a fool caricati suoni degli u2
oggetti dell'anno non ho capito bene
adesso va bene dovrei di leggerlo ma
sono stanco a leggere non ha senso piggy
bank è una merda vediamo in questo in
questo va bene va bene va bene ma
aumentato il danno ma aumentato il danno
è il range anche cos'è sì ma ventato il
danno e regge non è male meno male
perché faceva schifo l'altro allora
anche al capi up tra l'altro quindi
buonissimo dovrei sono sicuro di
prendere la 3 la la segreta ci vado
direttamente perché ho bisogno di di
un'altra chiave rare a vediamo no mica
non ci credo non ci posso credere non ci
posso credere
michela blend card mi serve tantissimo
la black card ragazzi mi serve proprio
come il pane perché la blank card imita
l'oggetto limita la carta che tu hai
sostanzialmente card mimico ok però devo
lasciare quello lì porco del demonio
maledetto eva ve lo lasciamo che doveva
cos'è questo nemico più
book of secrets cava sono capito cosa
fanno a chi svela le segrete parole
servì a niente avere è no usa la black
card ragazzi è troppo utile fa questo ha
però ha però attenzione però attenzione
hanno l'hanno cambiata adesso l'hanno
cambiata la devi foulard e ora è però è
sempre ottima e sempre sinergia col the
lovers raga non ce n'era gab line card
scusatemi è troppo forte e troppo forte
ko mi dispiace perché mi prendevo
oggetti dell'angelo conto da fare lì e
era veramente utile ragazzi a parte gli
scherzi però la black card con the
lovers è un peccato perché vanno filano
l'anno ne fa dalla mancata perché prima
aveva 8 madonna mi sono pagato prima
aveva quattro di ricarica adesso adesso
ne ha di più
ogni volta che la usi aumenta quanto
pare ed è un po lo schifo ed è un po uno
schifo ragazzi un po uno schifo però
però mi serve con the lovers non ci sono
kaki perché mica go cuori rossi e il
banner dark gambe li prende ragazzi
troppo è troppo forte
scusatemi ma l'auto magari ecco i pro
players di isaac non apprezzeranno
questa mossa
perdonatemi anzi chiedo già sclusa
ragazzi se le mie mosse non sono proprio
da proprio che comunque non è che sono
non ho non ho mai completato gioco al
cento per cento quindi non le so bene
tutte le cose c'è però mi definisco
comunque un average player quindi la
smettiamo di cagarmi sti tizi che mi
fanno prendere due infarti a botta ha
però vorrei che utile questo è perché ti
spinge via lele club e che non serve
arrivare dice non ci sono e puntina
highlights passa giulio steri caga una
botola si melaka gata meno male se non
mi faceva passare al turno al livello
successivo ma così è meglio è
spingi quell'affare ok questa cosa è
veramente utile ragazze almeno in certe
circostanze lo posso usare mi prende per
il culo gioco però che ci devo fare a
meno male ok faster extrusions veramente
non so se serve a qualcosa sta a fare lo
butterei subito che come minimo pio
danno però va beh
cos'è quello sta staminal qualcosa steam
celso kay shock sfida hpa telescope due
passaggi raga due passaggi niente male
due passaggi senza andare a piedi sotto
intendo due botole ok no
madonna hanno preso danno perfetto ok
sto per riattivare the lovers raga no
non l'ho visto ragno manche a meno che
non guardo dai a e devo pagare un
trinchetta anche perché se non fosse per
la porta di mamma no capirla posso farlo
perché poi mi caga le full sarà un
pericolo come si prende no sì sì me lo
ricordo che niente ci serve solo una
bomba perché non mi ricordavo è da un po
che non farle da un po che non gioca
raga sarà un paio di settimane quindi
non mi ricordo bene come si arriva da
the beast che voi non avete visto che
voi non avete visto quindi le scopo
almeno anche se perdo vi faccio vedere
qualcosa di nuovo due bombe non male ok
questa la sua prima di arrivare alla
mente per arrivare da the beast devo
fare un paio di me le spiego le mentre
che le faccio le cose o fra un po il i
trick dai angri mosca mazzano la moschea
incazzata vanno ogni tanto cemento non
ho ben capito come funziona e
sinceramente so solo che se io danno
quasi sono un pirla perfetto ok le
scuole let's go oltre bombe ragazzo
normale o la trade che ancora hanno
preso niente non so per quale motivo e
so perché ho lasciato indietro sono un
po un babbo adesso ci vado intanto la
minaccia ma possa fare comunque la che
incredibile io non sparo perché non
hamas ma ragazzi ho notato adesso che
spara lui braga l'ho notato adesso
perché io e ceo di tiro una botta è
bassa e poi mi tornò indietro ho notato
adesso che è lui che spara c'è veramente
non me non me n'ero accorto proprio e va
bene mi conviene tenerlo sempre attivo
quindi a sto punto c'è un uso tipo come
container friends o no ma forse mi
conviene tirare le botte la meglio non
tentare false false tattiche che già è
difficile sto gioco ci manca solo
ok è veramente figo raga molto
divertente e anche molto ma carlo perché
si apre la faccia ogni volta da questa
cosa con la batteria non la figlia
ora me la sento dopo il fungo rosso
visto come la senti madonna è
bruttissimo passare esclusione rega
fatemelo le varie tipo istantaneamente
con si leva così fatemelo levare perché
so già che mi pio danno io ok black card
ragazzi hills cop grazie va veramente
non solo a ringraziarti bambina qua no
ho sbagliato vabbè poi usarla per aprire
questo e allora chiave
detto questo è uno shock perché dovrei
aprirlo tanto non ho soldi se cliccate
sulle pubblicità dei video visto che ce
ne saranno tante magari mi arrivano i
soldi anche in gioco o no con gillet
dall asp e vi prego
allora leo stata più questo capirla o
stata ok non era come mi sembra con
genere friends per un attimo sbagliato
no passaggio non mi serve questo neanche
però vabbè
ok ho lasciato cosa indietro qualche non
ricordo se ho lasciato una stanza a sé
anche un sì posto lo prendo ragazzi va
bene kakà mi qualcosa
e i soft clubs praticamente trasforma
tutte le tutti gli oggetti nella stanza
li trasforma in bombe che non è male è
che non è male però ma sai che forse lo
uso qua facciamo così guarda se non mi
piace prendo lo prende poi giorno e il
convair tutti gli oggetti ma anche no
dai vabbè che forse non faccia a faccia
in realtà forse era meglio se lo faceva
vedere sti cazzi come vedete ragazzi
questa è una build con la blank card e
una build che si avvicina molto alla che
guarda molto la difesa del personaggio
no perchè attualmente sono full vita
praticamente tranne mezzocor e quindi
dovrei perché ovviamente dark bambi
sfama roba visto che sta usando la
plaine card dovrei trovare roba che
ovviamente al danno sostanzialmente
perché tanto adesso sono full a livello
di cuori se non faccio cagate aumento il
mio danno è questa una bella ragazza e
un poco efficace è posso far la stessa
cosa perché dicevo prima qua quindi va
bene vediamo
ma direi che è meglio che me lo prendo
addirittura ho troppi cuori rossi c'è
paradossalmente perché adesso con questo
ne arrivo arrivo a prenderne uno in più
va beh no veramente troppi laga
adesso mi servirebbe sì qualcosa per far
danno per far bene devo trovare
assolutamente lo rifarò sacrifices certo
sacrifices no non c'è e dovrei fare una
sacrifices dovrei prendere qualcosa
dell'angelo l'olio io questo ragazzi è
sempre stato un culo ok madonna però se
le basta fare c'è veramente incredibile
live view yes ciapalo addirittura
l'altro cuore e cioè incredibile
allora se io entro nel allora quello è
un bene già allora entrò qua dentro
mica non so cosa fa cioè quello l'aia
sinistra non solo da fare
aspetta che siccome ha un cuore in più
non è male se lo special se ne spendono
però non ho idea di cosa faccia quella
fare livello la cosa che era una specie
di cerchio sia bianco che nero la
prendiamo un attimo a maida ed eccolo
qua duali ti you feel the rebirth
ma allora non è male c'è nel senso spa
una sia in gergo che dave il rum
siccome leggerlo insomma di film el
angels sono difficili da trovare
io lo prenderei poi magari sto facendo
una cagata spara una sia l'ala è quella
di satana
ecco lo sapevo che piano anche danno
porco del demonio lo sapevo pure vabbè
tanto sono furneri ho recuperato subito
prendo il danno apcom e dai non ho
praticate quest'anno che si presentano e
disfa un bellissimo tease fa una stanza
dell'angelo è una stanza dedicata alle
scuole tutte e due
è utile più che altro perché far parlare
l'angelo non è facile e quindi adesso
almeno mi sparano più easy
poi ovviamente non me le posso prendere
tutte e due la già preso il cuore lo zio
fatto giro per questo ovviamente poi una
delle due scompare però sti cazzi cioè
nel senso che almeno miss parma più più
angelis e per sparare più angeli
sostanzialmente poi non so se ho fatto
una cagata non credo
l'ex girl posso posso avrai che anch'io
fa veramente schifo se lo ricorda il
meglio però secondo me non riesco a
rollarlo a meno che non trovi un oggetto
utile e vedremo vedremo
per ferrero lar lo devo trovare come ho
fatto qui a danno port col demonio per
regolarlo devo trovare sostanzialmente
una runa che che mi far annullare gli
oggetti che si chiamano di come sia ok
perfetto ko 1 i boss e il 3 schino stavo
banco visto perfetto è morto che kakà mi
qualcosa grazie sei veramente in ma
guarda non ho parole per descriverti
darkman mia cagato un ragno
vabbè comunque ragazzi domanda questa
non la so proprio sa cosa ma le cose che
ti caga il dark bam variano in base alla
lac cioè seriamente alla fortuna artista
una più facilmente cuori e se ne hai
poca distanza più facilmente ragni
questa la domanda che ovviamente non lo
so questi fontana lo caga delle lune
forze che non mi sbaglio non la cagata
va bene e se è così da vent armi anche
un po la lac che dovrei tornare qualcosa
che mi spara fuori
era meglio stato lasciato lì magari
provo un passaggio non ho la chiave
mannaia meno l'ha visto
dovrei trovare qualcosa che mi stavano i
cuori anche tipo durante le boxe fight
così almeno sei volte sul finale dark
bump può essermi ancora utile porca
vacca va bene o la chiavetta la chiave
toe trovato da allora e per fare bene
devo trovare qualcosa che ho vista una
più cuori rossi non so in che modo ho
dato danno
assurdo pergamene del mar morto fanno
schifo
porca non è che fanno schifo però la
black card cioè un'attiva item non mi
serve questo the book of eli al sia
dipende dalle stanze realtà però non mi
serve perché fauner fa un effetto
casuale dei libri se non sbaglio non
vorrei di una cagata
non vorrei di una cagata no fa un
effetto casuale sicuro non so se nei
libri qua non so come ho fatto a non
prenderla di ed baird la faccio no no
perché non tick a verona
o forse sì visto che un sacco di quelli
potrai che farla ma magari la fascia
dove adesso vedo stieg e siamo già 23
minuti di video ma di più forza 25 e
strano ragazzi fare un video senza che
ci sia un taglio molto figo tra l'altro
è strano per un aiuto perché fa sempre
taglia che lo dico
mamma mia ti sei ripreso la prima zio
ben attaccati 2
non male magari una sacrifices che dici
proprio così sporco lemonia no vai vai
vai o niente non lo prende lo prendono
prendere manaccia mi serviva lì mi
serviva perché se ti fai la sacri fai se
meglio se te lo tieni però mi sa che non
mi compare la sagra e poi scoprì no
perché non c'è la chiave la nonna o sono
chiavi anche a pagarne
the sun mannaggia the sun mannaia ecco
ma scusami sulla tela la domanda sopra
setosi design eco con blaine card adesso
ti aumenta ancora il perché praticamente
che cos'è che succede blank card
aumenta adesso secondo me in base alla
potenza della tua carta quindi se io uso
the sun che è fortissima che tifo lato
di cuori fa un casino
se io uso the sun adesso secondo me da
sé i cari che conterà 6 ci passa da
verne tipo tantissime quindi non mi
conviene usato con quello trovato manco
per sbaglio la runa quindi che mi
conviene prenderlo con l'oggetto aprendo
lo stesso non so ragazzi se tenere le
saranno the lovers ciò sta roba ma nasce
a me perché veramente utile del san lio
prende allora prendo the lovers perché
sono qua non ne sono sicuro ma quasi
la mia mente proprio la lazio non ne
sono sicuro ma quasi che perché sta
perciò in excite mannaia o male sono
sicuro ma quasi che mi aumenti il le
batterie per usare la carta quindi devo
tenere lovers poi parola quindi niente
dove the lovers sotto tengo the lovers
se la cavano un uso del sun nostro punto
lo uso quando lo uso non l'ho fatto
l'uso adesso cercando poi non posso
portare al piano di sotto in uso ad essa
stessa prendo la segreta perché sono
quasi sicura che l'unica volta che ho
usato blancardi condensandola quando c'è
repentance cioè la carta aveva 12 stack
ed è un po una schifo 12 st kim in alto
a sinistra è uno schifo perché non si
carica mai e quindi non mi come nave
reds hanno trovato da cup è bassa la
signora ga to the boss ma siamo certi
non he man mano che però sia piano di
mamma attenzione piatto danno posso
prendere ancora un danno senza perché
tanto c'è un cuore nero nell'altra
stanza ok vediamo solo tengo attivo se
fa danno e non riesco a prenderlo che
questo mi salta si fa danno ovunque come
fa più danno solo spam
perché almeno colpisco più easy e
fortissimo stappare raga unque non ho
capito sempre la l 30 g non ho capito
non ho capito ma tra l'altro devo andare
nel mausoleo no non do fra il mausoleo
per fare the beast mi che adesso mi è
giusto lapsus
ap a questo non devo andare nel mausoleo
per fare il bis no no non serve
minchia strade giusto la busi lapsus
incredibile mausoleo non solo me no però
non ne so non ci metterei la mano sul
fuoco ecco raja non ne ho idea porco del
tema trattato scusatemi ma non ho
sparato nell'angelo né satana ma che
sfiga e io ho preso il ricetto di stata
per cosa non ha sparato niente sto
schifo
vediamo se a sparare la naturale della
super segreta che sta tipo qua
proprio no niente buttato due bombe non
mi ricordo non mi ricordo non mi ricordo
se lo faranno solo io spero di no perchè
se no ho perso minchia raga possibile
che non mi ricordo
no perché devo fare il nostro è un ho
sbagliato
vado avanti non mi ricordo se mi devo
battere mamma nel mausoleo no ma non
penso ecco infatti no meno male
questa è la porta prior hybris tra
l'altro ho visto ho visto recentemente
un video di sabato dove arrivava a don o
come si chiama sigma dogma non mi
ricordo più il boss prima di the beast e
aveva lakhous card io l'ho battuto
appunto usando lakhous card perché già
due fasi colori che la seconda
incredibile appena appena me spuntata
ciotti nati in faccia lakhous card
perché era veramente troppo forte è
stata bella stanza o ok
carta di hybris normale non male e mi
conviene spalmare la carta che sono poi
non si ricarica e uso anche di express
non è male innanzitutto primo sta bomba
qua qua
e vabbè la madonna che mi sembra
un'esagerazione stai calmo anche meno
la facciata ciapa vajda cuamm
ok posso perdere tre cuori in questo
piano che non è male che non è male ecco
ricordiamoci che devo usare
assolutamente in questo piano va esploso
il teschio con l'aics perché mi deve
dare del full per tornare in via
prendete vi faccio vedere come si
sblocca del bis come si sblocca del bis
che si sblocca con quella porta strana
che avete vista adesso che sono tutte
sono spalmati in questo piano per aprire
quella porta di ribattere mamma prendere
una polaroid e tornare indietro no qua
non c'è un teschio che è una ics sopra
non equa però in tutto il piano lo devo
trovare tornare indietro e poi la possa
aprire sostanzialmente però non me lo fa
fare se non ho la polaroid perché andrà
perché avevo ancora argentato ok questo
c'è niente
mamma mia che odio stick wow che odio
che odio profondo quanto leggo 843 non è
male potrei trovare molto e devo levare
molto di più per fare del bis sono banco
lo guardo ok non ho ancora capito cosa
fanno sicuri quasi sì c'erano proprio
capito bene sono lento come la merda
ecco questo e book
no non è buffo el il mostro scusate e
dove chi è il test veroli il vostro m
molto forte spengono attimino questo e
poi sparo questo ok sto male
leggo abbastanza però possono fare
ancora di più danno non ha preso preso
da gigi qua potrei fare veramente la
sagra i files double act eve card nice
che è che è un po un e quando attacchi
la presa della ciabatta nella ciabatta
perché fa la davo le tim card mi pare
che attivi l'effetto della item che che
blank card che attiva l'effetto della
carta quindi è una cosa non so cosa
succede tra l'altro se si usi la carta
sud si paga il gioco che succede
entra in un loop infinito o sto
sbagliando io davo lech tv dovrebbe
attivare due volte leiten e quindi che
l'ater ne serve per attivare la carta
quindi stranissima non solo da succede
per la scienza potrei provare a farlo
sì
o cosa no no no no no no no no però no
no no no no no no minchia no ragazzi
però hanno portato nella error
no mi sono giocato tutto ma [ __ ]
sorda
no ragazzi vi prego ma portato nella
erano effettivamente non aveva succede
no ho buttato dhahran polacco del
demonio maledetto infame nora gancio io
credo l'ho buttato ahram perché non
posso tornare trazioni fa andare avanti
ma nasce a meo era veramente un ottimo
esperimento ma ha votato run porco
demonio maledetto fin dai
vabbè aiutano ziliani lo shock da
ragazzi minchia che palle ma non ci
posso pensare ma ha portato nella r
regali non ci posso credere non posso
tornare indietro solo nella a meno che
non non credo infatti finisce a meo
ma dai mi chiama che sfiga e monda non
c'è nessun modo per tornare indietro
porco demonia schifoso
dai ragazzi ma dai ma possibile ma porca
vacca me e niente evade ve l'ho detto
che succeda qualcosa di strano sta tutto
mi sarei aspettato tranne questo porca
put ansa
e niente o davanti e devo fà ho buttato
l'aran raga perché non ho battuto mamma
e quindi non posso tornare nella porta
non c'è modo di tornare indietro in
isaac poi solo poi sono scendere come
aldo baglio agli ex nel scendere e
salire rimango qua scendere posso non
posso salire però martian neo la brama
possibile ma possibile ma ormai succede
mia roba leggere in un video sta andando
sta andando tutto bene cit domenico bini
al contrario ragazzi e ho perso ad altro
per prender quello dei vip passano
perché posso tirarmi dietro ok ci
arriverà me mandare non ci posso pensare
ma come cacchio il bus ma come è
possibile dai raga veramente fatti seri
michela euro sono dovuto nella error
l'ho vista quattro volte da quando gioco
ad isaac da subito la a error
vabbè possibile regalo d'altro tra
l'altro non è neanche la polaroid quindi
non ho modo di è pure non ho
assolutamente modo di fare niente dopo
il cuore di mamma ce la faccio quali
mamme fine ho buttato una rampa f
perfetta nova quasi c'è veramente era
ottima sarà nicchia ragazzi vabbè dai
basta piange ci sorprendiamo avanti non
utilizzate la double active card quando
quando state colla con la black card
mannaie che possa essere d'aiuto a tutti
youtubers là fuori che una cacata del
genere di rovinare youtubers e non sono
player di isaac in generale soprattutto
youtubers che magari stanno facendo un
video e buttano al vivo cioè io non
penso di potasso video solo ed
esclusivamente perché credo di essere
l'unico ad aver fatto stack agata però
intanto ho preso due danni in faccia
quindi dato un sacco di cuori c'è tutto
ha cosparso in quel piano niente preso
l'ha fatta la cosa più brutta è voto fa
senza polare senza niente neanche le
speranze giorni eppure
ecco dai quanto tempo al brown si allea
betsy la sacri poi finalmente dopo sei o
allora che non mi serve più sono
contento ragazzi a parte gli scherzi che
vi sia piaciuto isaac sin da subito
perché è difficile sostanzialmente
portare giochi su youtube anche che
giochi tu per i cazzi tuoi
c'è in genere quello che tu porti sul
canale non è uno youtuber quello che
porta sul canale non è necessariamente
quello che lui gioca per i fatti suoi
a volte sì a volte no io per esempio non
sono uno di quelli che se ne porta
quello che gioca per i fatti suoi e
isaac è una di quelle poche volte che
ma ultimamente era di realtà nell'ultimo
negli ultimi due anni sono sempre
portando roba che mi piace
magari cerco di fare una media tra le
cose che piace al piacere al pubblico
così via solamente una volta faceva
riportato solo quello che piaceva al
pubblico oggi no oggi porto faccio una
media tra le due cose qua preso andando
un pirla e e isaac cosa che piace
totalmente a me non è pubblico
questo prima invece adesso iniziato a
piacermi la cosa mi mi fa molto piacere
per questo motivo
grazie ragazzi nel supporto vabbè che
vedo
ma non ci sta davanti perché ne in
groppa
per ora devo anche colpire come faccio
ecco ora il vero fortissimo buttato
tutto però l'ho buttato tra l'altro mi è
comparso anche sbaglio non allora si
certo per compreso dualità che pirla
dicevo perché se sbaglio non potrebbe
suonare l'angelo quando non c'è stata
no certo la persona perché c'è la
dualità quindi andiamo nel angelo guarda
guarda guai a volte guarda cosa o cosa
va preso porca vacca cosa cosa ma
sparatori questi non lo manco visto
mannaggia a me o niente ragazzi preso
anche l'angelo niente la fa pero
dovrebbero mettere qualcosa per tornare
su comunque sarebbe ferito tornay sono i
piani specialmente quando la gente come
0 finale run mannaia almeno provare una
micro speranza tipo no
comunque ragazzi senza tagli discorsi
che faccio non so se hanno senso generi
una roba come discorso di prima del
portale contenuti avrei tagliata perché
non ne sono stato per molto chiaro non
mi sono capito manco io però ho detto
che lo faccia senza tagli senza tagli
sarà calcoli riassumere verrà però
ovunque stavo dicendo semplicemente che
ultimamente porto le robe che mi
piacciono
questa è una particolare eccezione
perché ultimamente sta piacendo anche a
voi
sono contento l'avrei portato comunque
però sono contento che vi piaccia
cosa che certo ha tra l'altro ragazzi
adesso arriva al cuore di mamma e
finisce la tristezza al mondo per la una
tristezza che fa veramente ridere
a meno che non mi si fa un i delirium ma
la vedo impossibile ma [ __ ]
ma posso prendere danno sempre che palle
le facciamo ancora intatte non c'ho
voglia che guarda giusto perché sono
pigro neanche non c'era anche la scusa
non so segreto qua ecco
oh yeah più per chi
c'è una stanza dei libri nuovo vista
l'avevamo prevista per la valvola non è
una stanza intessuta da una libreria
meno male che un miliardo di chiavi
dai dai kakanj cuori maledetto pure tu
bravo lo zio
mica ragazzi faccio disastri cioè
possibile che sono riuscito a buttare
punto blastociste blastocisti mio posto
preferito fa schifo è veramente scarso
ok sfida ora grazie
nice lo sapevo che devono saper osare
usac su è la sacri testi nuovo sono solo
le solo quale sacrifices in chiave e non
so piùa black card io veramente non ci
posso credere tanto se faccio se faccio
tanto la sacrifices mimì mi butta nel
medico come cioè niente ciò i lapsus
lapsus cioè lapsus oggi sarebbe da fare
con la sacri files perché a me non
importa niente non mi ricordo come si
chiama dove c'è the lamp va bene non mi
ricordo non so per quale motivo gioco a
questo gioco da sei anni non mi ricordo
come si chiama il posto d'estate lamp va
bene ho fatto solo 20 mila volte
ecco
ma premetto che non mi è mai successo
che di di non prendere una polaroid ok
quindi non mi ha mai riva mai successo
di arrivare al cuore di mamma senza
prendere la polaroid di mamma che è
quella che mi sono saltato ma non
dovrebbe spawn armi né questo né questo
o forse la polaroid e serve per suonarci
il boss che sta dopo la cattedrale
quindi del decesso
questo qua invicibili ti attacca cost
che sarebbe non ho idea di quale sia il
costo ma va bene quindi niente ho fatto
una gaffe io la polaroid serve
semplicemente al piano qui di pulse
ancora fare la cattedra sostanzialmente
facciamo la cattedrale
no no lì sotto rendiamoci a difficile
che ovviamente la cattedrale secondo me
è più facile non lo chef quello dopo lo
shell come cacchio si chiamano mi
ricordo mai più come faccia essere una
dimenticato aperto probabilmente satana
e poi mi finisce perché non la polaroid
cage
no perché non aveva mai non ero mai
arrivato dai quali mamma senza la paura
non è quindi effettivamente pensava non
ti sparo ma se proprio lo chef o la
catedral invece non ho detto una cagata
io ok ai mici invincibili eta cost ma
quale cost a far bocca storta ma ha
tirato una botta non so quale sia il
costo ragazzi la uso in una stanza dove
soliti ad anna vediamo quale cost
se ci arrivava che verso due cuori con
un pirla ecco
non l'ho presa così
io li odio questi sono veramente infami
che fastidio io sempre odiati sti qua
c'è una dark room
vabbè fantasmi lemaire da re rolla però
la tutto il piano tutti gli oggetti di
tutto il piano è un diventi c'è però la
tutti gli oggetti no ma ho preso il
cuore a questa nuova regola tutti gli
oggetti di tutto il piano stanzialmente
prendiamo tutti gli oggetti tutto il
piano
o ce l'ha chi cerca stalinisti umani tir
ag a cercar sacristi umani che non è
male cazzo che stima di tipo niente ti
crei una stanza piena di merda con plan
card l'avrei ca ecco avrei cambiato the
lovers con black card
perché è veramente troppo forte a meno
che non aumenta anzi sicuramente sarebbe
aumentato il debito l'acquisto sarebbe
aumentato il la batteria
devo trovare dovrei trovare una stanza
di quelle grosse non questa però
qualcosa di grosso sarebbe output super
utile lo sapevo non lo deve fare per
forza danno 2
ma che ammazza mi ammazza vi prego
uccidimi buoni fina la mia esistenza
adesso ma tutto tre cuori 314 forse
porca [ __ ] ma possibile
bob e tre cuori imbarazzante ragazzi
imbarazzante lo giuro l'ho sempre
attento c schiatto per farmi capire 1 2
3 e 4
devo trovare una stanza di quelle giga
raga va bene anche quella di prima è
però queste non le prendo perché
veronica che palle
è persino in groppa non dà invece no
more rollero tutti sti soldi con la
davis
ok questo è mio sorry bomba
e e rollo perché ho fatto ho preso
talmente tanto danno che devo
assolutamente aumentarmi cuori e
soprattutto lo faccio una volta che ho
usato carta che insieme a nicky perché
almeno crollo anche gli oggetti nelle
cacche che a volte sono kakà tè nero
senza parole cos'è questo essi speed
down sicuro per sicurezza giusto perché
non mi ricordo mai fare forse spinta un
punto chiamava o gli averi
no lo prende dov'è che vadano c'è ancora
qualcosa da fare quasi
speed up kamau manca non poche stanze
poi airolo il piano non la prendo questa
tanto con quei principi di eta costa non
ho mica capito qual è il costo lo giuro
che non l'ho capito ho schiacciato prima
so quale sia non lo voglia di cercarlo
tanto non mi serve il coraggio
ok
va bene ragazzi allora kalsa christie
umani t lamela metto la metto la metto
non qua ok per questo lo prendo però
questo lo prendo perché le vorrei
rollare il piano quindi al senso che lo
prenda questo la provincia qualcosa ok
la metto qui faccio esplodere tutte le
cassette se trovo il tri ict della cacca
meraviglioso madonna che bello quanto le
cacche che esplodono possa fare
fantastico
eccolo che culo con questo incredibile
ragazzi perché meno spanò un miliardo di
oggetti lascia meno mi serviva il cuore
rosso ma mai lamentato nera un miliardo
di hang drum and bass da bam si prenderà
i cuoriosi vabbè fa niente importante
poi mica lì fuori gli altri ok
si vabbè regala è finita è finita è
troppo forte calza inizio marini raga
non ce n'è qualche europa si trova
presente un miliardo di robben e nelle
carte sostanzialmente adesso ovviamente
devo stare attenta a non prendere le
monete perché le rollo tutto vivere che
succede se esco di qua che questa fare
riprendere gli altri cuori e meglio
adesso mi pagherà un miliardo di nova
guarda
ok va bene è un'altra roba 6 voglia e
sun madonna de zordo tuo fiuto vorrei
sul tuo marito chi ha cioè questo che
faccio in clausi non ne serve che stanno
per tengo the sun e vado a regolare il
piano mangiamo che succede
novelli rollato così tanta roba ok ti
chiami cagherà l'impossibile strength
the sun
mi serve di più è che a questa è una
della aree lo re non la sola stanza a
che pirla
ero convinto che non lascia il piano va
bene il terreno lava che merda allora ma
scusate mi fa schifo veramente orribile
se tirerò la sola stanza fa schifo per
sovrano classe proprio tutto il piano ok
si sveglierà che scopro sempre cose
giocando perché non sono totalmente
esperto di popsophia quest'invasione
recitavamo confetti dovete sante si
vabbè ormai non mi sarebbe un cazzo sta
roba questa al vostro stalla intanto è
l'ultimo c'è per morire da satana per
essere veramente un pirla rega e fu così
che schiaccia i un'altra cagata che
quando ci sono le manette doppie noti
dalla capelli tanto st
un altro compressa porca [ __ ] un
azzecco mai il timing lo è la tullow
dzeko sempre ma non cerco mai nei video
qualche miliardo di danno va bene va
bene per ammazzare al mazza per massa
massa toglimi tutto quello che vuoi
a il costo dell'invincibilità è
semplicemente la batteria non è anche
perché pensa euro lo sto usando per
testarlo mano e non ma non è non è vero
ma colpito uguale cazzata totale non ho
capito non so come si usa spesso va bene
vediamo
e se arriva alla fine prendo danno
sicuro guarda a noi a libici vita sia
arrivare si attiva alla fine è finito
raga peccato perché è sta cazzo di arrow
room ne è uscita la formula peccato è
stata la run divertente peccato per la
error
peccato veramente però almeno abbiamo
abbiamo visto che funziona thain tellini
e ho fatto un video uncut che non è mai
successo
cinquanta minuti ne anzi quasi un'ora
secondo me è divertente è stato figo
ragazzi vi ringrazio per aver visto il
video questo era il mio di oggi grazie
del fatto che siete riusciti a seguire
aida che specialmente per il fatto che
ho iniziato a portare la propria che è
un gioco che piaceva a me e non è il
classico gioco per fare virus
ok perché non ci sono titoli click mail
però a me piace lo porto e ultimamente
vi è piaciuto molto di più rispetto a un
tempo quindi posso anche per il sì nuovo
quindi vi ringrazio cigliano il prossimo
episodio vediamo riuscire ad arrivare a
the beast magari del prossimo senza
arrivare nelle rose room spacco tutto
anche perché almeno arrivarci non è
difficile
sono sincero e farlo che è difficile fa
tensione con riuscirci iori grazie
previsto fischietti del kailash ad un
commento che sotto non mi piace e noi
come sempre da mille anni a questa parte
ormai c2 di andare al prossimo vi è la
ragazza
[Musica]